[Musica]
la bocciato sbocciato è Mi fa molto
ridere però prima di iniziare voglio
chiedere ai presenti Quanti di voi sono
stati bocciati a scuola
Dai dai avevo il terrore perché le prove
ho provato quanti bocciati tutti così
no allora mi sentivo un po' da solo
adesso non mi sento più da solo no vi
dicevo mi fa molto ridere perché
rappresenta perfettamente due periodi
ben distinti della mia vita ovvero dai
14 ai 23 anni per cui il periodo
scolastico che per me è stato lungo
quindi
superiori università e poi il periodo
dai 23 ai 27 No dai 23 ai 31 del della
scoperta quindi sbocciato doppio
significato tra sbocciare magari come un
fiore per cui finalmente trovi la tua
via oppure sbocciare in senso proprio
bottiglia era proprio un gioco di parole
così che mi faceva piacere portarvi Oggi
quando sono stato chiamato da Jessica
per essere qua oggi mi ha detto Giorgio
tu parlerai di aria e effettivamente Io
potrei parlare di aria perché lancio
oggetti per aria Io lavoro tantissimo
con la gravità però
pensavo che fosse qualcosa di limitante
perché si può parlare Sì di Che cos'è il
flare del mio lavoro però l'area di cui
volevo parlare oggi è un'area diversa è
un'area di cambiamento che non possiamo
percepire intorno a noi ma arriva
l'esatto momento in cui ho veramente
bisogno di sentire quell'area e quel
momento Esatto è arrivato Esattamente
tra lo switch tra bocciato e sbocciato
ai 23 anni preciso là e mi fece una
domanda e la domanda è se io avessi la
certezza di non poter fallire che cosa
farei quale sarebbe il mio scopo ora
questa domanda Mettiamola da parte come
abbiamo fatto praticamente su tutto il
tè da una domanda la metto da parte e
andiamo a vedere qual è stato il mio
percorso io ero il classico ragazzo
bravo ma che non si applicava ma perché
non mi applicavo perché non volevo
andare a scuola anche ma non mi
applicavo perché la mia infanzia è stata
molto turbolenta Ho passato praticamente
dalla nascita Fino all'età
dell'adolescenza avendo un problema
talloni Io sono nato senza i talloni per
cui no ce li ho Eh ci sono però non sia
la calcificato per cui si chiama morbo
di sever e in pratica tu non puoi fare
attività sportiva non potendo fare
attività sportiva cadi in una serie di
cose consequenziali tra cui aumento di
peso perché nell'età giovanile aumenti
di peso non puoi fare tanti tipologie di
sport che tutti i ragazzini della tua
età fanno per cui cosa succede vieni
messo in una classe sempre in disparte
ammetti quello metti un ragazzo timido
so che magari oggi non sembra però è
timido impacciato leggermente in
sovrappeso ero il prototipo perfetto per
il ragazzo che veniva messo da parte
quindi questo mi faceva andare a scuola
senza voglia demoralizzato ed è così che
esci due anni in ritardo dalle superiori
una volta che esci dici vabbè dai mi
butto sul lavoro che ho capito che forse
di studiare non è che è proprio la
massima cosa invece no decido di seguire
una fantastica idea di un mio amico e di
iscrivermi a Giurisprudenza semplice
facile facile
lui inizia lascia dopo due settimane io
Tosto duro 2 anni all'incirca dando
sette esami passandone solitamente uno
questo mi doveva dare
un po' una è uno stand up Comedy
Incredibile
Questo mi doveva dare un po' un senso di
Giorgio sta succedendo qualcosa che
forse non sta andando bene e questo
campanello d'allarme però non ti arriva
perché se nella ruota del criceto perché
la società ti ha messo nelle condizioni
di dire se tu sei in ritardo sei un
fallito io a 23 anni Esatto quindi in
quattro anni in ritardo rispetto alla
tabella di marcia di un ragazzo i miei
coetanei si laureavano iniziavano gli
stage in qualche studio importante e io
li guardavo e dicevo Ma io sono fuori
non riesco a passare gli esami
però non te ne rendi conto me ne fece
rendere conto mia madre che un giorno
arrivò e mi disse Giorgio forse non è il
tuo forse è il momento che inizi a
vedere qualcosa magari una professione
cosa ti appassiona ero apatico perché
ero realmente stavo diventando realmente
una depressione molto molto brutta e in
quel momento decisi di affidare di
affidarmi ai corsi di mia madre e scoprì
il mondo del bar appunto mi consiglia di
fare un mondo un corso di flirt
bartending cioè scusate di bartending
vado a fare il corso di barman e vedo
l'insegnante di allora Matteo Melara che
lancia uno shaker dietro la schiena dico
no Ma cos'è e mi fa guarda Fleur
bartending Allora non so Sicuramente il
flareon è una parola che che vi suona
tanto familiare vi spiego un attimino
cosa Cosa significa flir significa
L'arte di fare qualcosa con stile classe
ed eleganza ovviamente applicato al
mondo del bartending Fleur bartender
significa fare il barman con stile ora
se voi pensate a quello che vi ho detto
prima ero totalmente l'opposto
impacciato non parlavo con le persone
poca socialità cioè come potevo farlo
Però decido lo stesso di buttarmi in
questo no decido di provarci e come ogni
corso prevede un esame Io l'ho fatto in
parallelo all'università per vedere di
tenermi comunque due strade parallele in
modo tale che Ma va male una proprio
L'altra l'altra era sicura che andasse
male una cosa andava avanti a fare
quindi cosa succede
l'esame di flare capita nello stesso
identico giorno dell'esame di diritto
privato vado a dare l'esame di diritto
privato la mattina ovviamente non so
neanche raccontarvelo vengo bocciato
malamente
nel pomeriggio io contento di questo
bocciatura Per la prima volta Vado ad
affrontare un Sono contento di
divertirti
Vado ad affrontare un
esame di flare arrivo ad affrontare
l'esame di flare e inaspettatamente
vengo bocciato
bene grazie Se mi disgrazie sono la
vostra gioia sono contento
Grazie
[Applauso]
molto bene
vengo bocciato questo fa molto ridere
vengo bocciato e torno a casa Torna a
casa e vado da mia madre e
nei suoi occhi quando ovviamente quando
io dico dei suoi occhi io non ho visto
una delusione per l'ennesimo fallimento
vedo uno sguardo dispiaciuto vedo uno
sguardo di una mamma che non sa non sa
perché il figlio non riesce a trovare la
propria strada e questo a me distrusse
il cuore fondamentalmente io solo mia
madre per cui è normale che ai tempi un
ragazzino di 23 anni
soffra per questo per cui io passo una
settimana realmente molto molto pesante
da dove Da quella settimana sono
riuscito a tirare fuori quella domanda
che vi ho fatto prima per cui l'aria del
cambiamento ho dovuto ho dovuto avere un
uno shock molto forte per tirare fuori
il nuovo me e inizia a cambiare il mio
modo di vivere la vita e di vivere Gli
ostacoli non ho più pensato a bocciature
in termini di fallimento ho iniziato a
pensare che ogni sconfitta era
semplicemente una lezione nuova Allora
ho iniziato ad affrontare la vita in
questo modo andando sempre contro a
tutte le
sfortune o comunque le bocciature che
poi nel mio termine nelle gare magari
significano gli ultimi posti e non mi
sono mai praticamente focalizzato
sull'errore ma sono sempre cercato di
andare avanti ed imparare ed è da lì che
ho iniziato a chiedere cosa bisognava
fare per diventare realmente un
personaggio di successo nel mio mondo
nel mondo del flirt Terni e mi dissero
guardato basta allenarsi Va bene basta
allenarsi ci proviamo ho iniziato ad
allenarmi dalle 4 ore alle 6 alle 8 ore
al giorno lavorando gratis per potermi
permettere le attrezzature perché
costano le attrezzature Ma se io devo
andare ad allenarmi pagare un affitto e
non ci sto dentro devo anche lavorare
Devo potermi allenare per cui ero super
distrutto psicologicamente dal fatto che
non fosse una roba troppo semplice ma
comunque ci sono sempre andato ed è sono
stati otto anni perché sono veramente
volati dove In questi otto anni di
sacrifici sono riuscito ad ottenere
tutto quello che prima hanno detto
quindi non starò a ripeterlo E
oltretutto sono riuscito anche a ad
andare in televisione adesso sto
scrivendo un libro e riesco anche a
collaborare con personaggi del calibro
di chef Alessandro Borghese che
per me dai tempi Ovviamente è un vanto
ma questo come succede questa scintilla
personale al discorso della dell'area
del cambiamento la scintilla ti scoppia
ti scatta esattamente quando inizia ad
avere la motivazione io
differenzio questo percorso in quattro
motivazione disciplina visione e
obiettivo
punto di riferimento la motivazione
Ovviamente per avete capito Per me è
stato lo sguardo di mia madre che mi ha
fatto scattare in me qualcosa la
disciplina è l'ha detto anche prima il
dottor Mattia è ovviamente In altri
termini però la disciplina è quello che
ti permette di ottenere il tuo obiettivo
perché io come adesso lui non non mi
ponevo delle domande con il devo ma Mi
Mi ponevo delle domande con il voglio
perché lo voglio per me stesso io non
devo andare ad allenarmi Io voglio
andare ad allenarmi perché diventerò più
bravo
e la disciplina però non basta perché
senza una visione chiara di dove voglio
andare non posso arrivarci perché sennò
andrei a sbattere in giro Io sapevo
esattamente dove volevo arrivare ma
questa la terza è la più difficile
perché la visione la vedete solo voi non
potete chiedere ai vostri genitori alle
vostre mogli mariti compagni fidanzati
di avere la stessa visione che avete voi
Voi vedete sempre cose diverse e sempre
cose che gli altri non riescono a vedere
per cui la visione è forse la più
importante delle 4 l'ultima è
l'obiettivo puntato la persona per voi
di riferimento e cercate di capire lui
cosa è stato disposto a fare per
ottenere quell'obiettivo io prima di
lasciarvi Voglio lasciare una piccola
riflessione che faccio un attimo assieme
poi la spiego anche
c'è una frase molto bella che dice di
non impazzire a cercare di catturare le
farfalle ma piuttosto impiegare quelle
energie nel creare un giardino
Rosio In modo tale che le farfalle
arrivino ora questa frase bellissima
perché se noi la trasportiamo nei nostri
obiettivi nella vita non cerchiamo di
impazzire nel cercare di raggiungere le
farfalle che sono i nostri obiettivi ma
piuttosto impieghiamo quelle energie per
coltivare il giardino che siamo noi
stessi per far sì che quegli obiettivi
arrivino direttamente noi vi ringrazio
[Applauso]